josephine está resolviendo el siguiente
problema para su tarea 5 que multiplica
a x 7 elevado al cuadrado esto es igual
a 245 completa el problema como se ve en
los pasos siguientes
josephine realiza estos tres pasos que
tenemos aquí y cuando llega a la escuela
el día siguiente su profesora les dice
que la respuesta es x igual a 0
x igual a menos 14 ella solamente llevó
a que la respuesta era x igual a 0 en
que pasó cometió un error y bueno aquí
tenemos el paso número 1 pero antes de
aplicarnos en los pasos quiero que tú
pases este vídeo e intentes encontrar la
respuesta a este problema por ti mismo
ok una vez que ya estoy suponiendo que
pausas del vídeo vamos a ver qué dice en
el primer paso lo que tiene es esta
ecuación de kim 5 que multiplica a x 7
elevado al cuadrado esto es igual a 245
y entonces si te das cuenta de esta
primera igualdad que tengo aquí
y bueno lo que josephine es que
tendríamos que dividir todo entre 5 y lo
dividió de una manera adecuada ya que lo
hizo de ambas partes para mantener
balanceada la igualdad dijo si divido
esta parte en 35 me queda solamente x +
7 elevado al cuadrado mientras que del
lado derecho desde igualdad si divido
245 entre 5 voy a llegar a 49 y hasta
aquí vamos bien ahora de esta segunda
igualdad a esta tercera igualdad hizo el
paso 2 lo que hizo fue darse cuenta que
aquí arriba tengo x + 7 elevado al
cuadrado y para convertirlo en x + 7 lo
que tiene que hacer es sacar raíz
cuadrada por lo tanto dijo bueno voy a
sacar la raíz cuadrada de este lado
izquierdo y me va a quedar la raíz
cuadrada de x + 7 elevado al cuadrado lo
cual es x + 7 y del lado derecho también
sea con la raíz cuadrada de 49 la raíz
cuadrada de 49 es 7 y justo aquí fue
donde hizo un pequeño pero muy muy
muy importante error ella tiene x más
siete elevado al cuadrado igual a 49 y
cuando toma la raíz cuadrada de este
lado izquierdo le queda x + 7 mientras
que del lado derecho va a tomar la raíz
cuadrada tanto positiva como negativa de
49 10 por eso que x + 7 es igual a 7
porque 7 al cuadrado es 49 pero también
x más 7 es igual a menos 7 porque menos
7 al cuadrado también es 49 y justo aquí
es donde perdió una de las soluciones
solamente puso que x + 7 es igual a 7
cuando realmente debería de decir que x
7 es igual a más menos 7 en el paso
número 2 es donde olvidó tomarse la raíz
positiva y negativa de 49 por lo tanto
fue en el paso 2 fue en el paso 2 en
donde ella perdió la otra solución
perfecto estamos bien